bonjour ici le dr matis oui date de
naissance de février 1998
dr matis
noah vous aviez tort aura regarde-moi
regarde moi donne moi c'est vers l'est
sous la dent alors c'est la date
anniversaire 2 1 de quoi aimerais tu
parles et aujourd'hui j'ai besoin
d'aider les gens je peux pas ça fait
trop longtemps que j'ai vite chez un
patient qui souffre de stress post
traumatique
bonjour vous êtes alex et si tu veux
qu'on me dise comment vivre avec ça
c'est ce qu'un thérapeute est censé
faire je ne me vois plus 10 a saisi
j'arrête pas de retourner dans cet
endroit en pensez vous avez une idée de
ce que je ressens vous avez quoi j'ai
aussi aux habitants
si c'est vrai j'aime c'est juste que
guillaume
ben quoi je ne perçois plus de progrès
elle perd blessés il faut arrêter d'y
penser dans cette gamme l'art et
j'arrête pas de voir leur âge je crois
que je suis en train de devenir folle